let's jump to the story from CNN my
friends this is big big news and they
buried the lead no jokes CNN buried the
lead check this out so here's here's
what it says mid article CNN from today
survey more than 80 percent of Americans
16 and older have immunity the survey
led by the CDC also indicates that about
twice as many people have been infected
with the virus uh as have been
officially counted more than 39 million
Americans have been diagnosed with covet
infections since the pandemic started in
2020. the team led by the cdc's Dr
Jefferson Jones set out to determine how
close the U.S might be to some kind of
herd immunity although they do not claim
to have any kind of handle on that yet
they worked with 17 blood collection
organizations working in all the 50
states plus DC and Puerto Rico to test
blood covering 74 of the population in
the end they tested
1.4 million samples I know Ian you were
asking about the sample size 1.4 million
in July 2020 before any vaccine was
available 3.5 percent of samples carried
antibodies to SARS covid II that Rose to
11.5 by December by May 83.3 percent of
samples had antibodies to the virus most
of them from vaccination
epic now here's the funny part let's
what's the actual story CNN says U.S
states that have that had some some the
worst wait what
yeah
covid-19 case rates in past week also
reported the highest rates of new
vaccinations so this is CNN.com we got
it pulled up I'm showing you got the
News Guard wow newsguard says CNN
doesn't handle the difference between
opinion and news responses thank you
News Guard come on the show someday
that's a good call out mind you
um but but this is it this is CNN health
and they straight up are saying 80 of
American 16 or older have immunity let
me show you this from Forbes top U.S
officials including fauci previously
estimated that herd amenity threshold to
be about 60 to 70 percent of the
population deeming that goal reachable
once vaccines were available yo it
sounds like the vaccines worked there's
a couple things real quick it sounds
like operation warp speed worked yeah
Joe Biden moved up the timeline of
vaccines by about a month sounds like
that worked and it sounds like now based
on CNN's reporting of CDC data of
reviewing 1.4 million samples 80 percent
have immunity due to the vaccines this
is this is cost for celebration right
everybody should be really happy about
this let the Roaring 20s begin yeah yeah
we're there let's do it my two questions
are one are these immunity have they
developed immunity for a different
strain like the alpha strain when we
have the Delta strain out now and two
have they developed partial immunity as
opposed to Total immunity are they
different can you have partial immunity
instead of considered immune it's a good
question uh they say this was all
pre-delta the researchers caution plus
they didn't measure the other part of
the human response one involving cells
in his T cells and one that might endure
use broader immunity but knowing who has
antibodies can help inform public health
health efforts quote several large
Studies have shown that among
individuals who are Sarah positive from
prior SARS covet to infection covid-19
incidence is reduced by 80 to 95 percent
similar to vaccine efficacy estimates
they noted the study will continue until
at least December 2021 and results will
be made available on the cdc's website
they wrote you see
there we go that said the people that
have had it have also well they've they
were referencing the other the part of
the study where it said that people who
have caught covid have similar immunity
to those who have been who've been
excellent this is the CDC you know what
at YouTube might not be happy with us I
don't know but this is good news
regardless of politics this is what we
were aiming for two years a year and a
half ago and this is I mean ultimately
immunity is what we're looking for or
some sort of resistance I mean this is
amazing so in light of this news we can
expect for all the local and state
governments and the federal government
to start rolling back all their
regulations to start making adjustments
to the whole lockdown situation we've
been living through for the past 15 16
months there's nothing more permanent
than a temporary government we'll see
the populations making that happen as we
see in that with the kids walking out
exactly I don't I don't I don't know
what what you what what to say to you
other than uh share this with people let
them know the good news and I genuinely
mean this this is good news this is
fantastic this event absolutely 83.3
percent according to the CDC survey so
we need to start taking that
consideration because now it's time to
bring the economy back help our our kids
get everyone back on track and it's time
to celebrate declare Victory and to all
the the people who are uh you know I'll
say it right now all the people in the
big cities and all those Democrats who
are like vaccine vaccine vaccine
congratulations you did it you got
enough people vaccinated at least
according to this so far
um maybe it's a little preliminary but
if this if we're basing our judgments
off CDC data and this is the survey led
by the CDC well then there we go maybe
that's that's it's time to Rob let's go
to the movies fauci came out on Fox news
said that the moo covet variant is not
an immediate threat to Americans I don't
know if we're going to talk about this
story at all but that's very promising
as well because if it's it's continuing
to evolve this virus and it's just
according to fauci not going to be a
threat then it is a good future I mean
you know what it sounds like it sounds
like we had a real risk with a novel
virus that came out last year maybe we
overreacted some people did really awful
things like Cuomo he's a bad guy and uh
dude this is what we said last year all
last year the issue was that because it
was a novel it was likely to spread
rapidly and so we were like we got to
slow the spread well maybe a year and a
half you know and a vaccine to slow the
spread was a little bit more than we
thought was going to happen but at this
point do we now just say like all right
let's let's let's start bringing things
back let's bring back the businesses the
movies the restaurants drop the mandates
I think we should put that on the table
for sure yeah for sure well this is so
interesting to me too because I think it
was just last week we were talking about
I think it was Thomas Massey tweeted out
a study about how natural immunity is at
least comparable to vaccine immunity and
he that tweet was super restricted you
couldn't respond to it this was an
Israeli study that hadn't been
peer-reviewed yet and they were treating
it like it was absolutely lies and it
turns out that it definitely wasn't this
is entirely the case so they're not just
talking about vaccination here they're
also talking about like being recovered
from it I think that was the tweet that
someone tweeted at him like what would
you know you're not a scientist and he
tweeted back his diploma from MIT with
like masters in science
pretty damn funny I thought that was
pretty good I love him um but I guess
the question will be coming from this is
in terms of government in terms of
government overreach was all this for
our own good and and obviously there's
an argument about whether or not
government should even be caring about
our own good or was about something
larger because if we're hitting this
herd immunity and we're heading in the
right direction and and and we're
celebrating and bring back the freedoms
Etc if if it doesn't start rolling back
well then you know this was all just a
load of of bunk right so that will be
the real question which I think has
people genuinely concerned I don't think
I don't think you're going to see
governments saying like hey look we
solved this problem and now everything
will go back to normal so that will be a
huge question I have I have I have a
question for all you guys uh you
mentioned that the Pfizer bionic vaccine
is FDA approved
I don't remember which one one of them
is well didn't one just get FDA approval
Community I believe I don't remember
which one it's a version Tim's probably
going to start talking a little bit more
about this it's a version of the Pfizer
bio and Tech virus uh vaccine called
Community it's basically the exact same
formulation but what they did is give it
a they gave it a name a proprietary name
oh and then the FDA approved that so the
Pfizer bio insect one is still not
approved even though it's the exact same
one so it's it's like the distinct legal
names have a difference but this matters
and I'll tell you why we have this from
the fda.gov FDA approves first covid-19
vaccine they say this is August 23rd
today the U.S uh usfda approved the
first covid-19 vaccine the vaccine has
been known as the Pfizer bioentec
covid-19 vaccine and will now be
marketed as Community for the prevention
of covid-19 disease in individuals 16
years of age and older community it's
called no it's Community
okay thank you the vaccine also
continues to be available under
emergency use authorization station
including for individuals 12 through 15
years of age and for the administration
of a third dose in certain
immunocompromised individuals so I guess
they're not they're advising bushes we
haven't gotten to the booster Point yet
I think some people have already gotten
them but uh they they do mention it is
uh that so basically the Pfizer biotech
vaccine
is going to be the same formula marketed
as community and that is FDA approved
okay let me read another paragraph for
you from fda.gov under Section 564 of
the federal Food Drug and cosmetic act
when the Secretary of HHS declares that
an emergency use authorization is
appropriate FDA May authorize unapproved
medical products or unapproved uses of
approved medical products to be used in
an emergency to diagnose treat or
prevent serious or life-threatening
diseases or conditions caused by cbrn
threat agents when certain criteria are
met including there are no adequate
approved and available Alternatives the
HHS declaration to support such use must
be based on one of the four types of
determinations of threats or potential
threats by the Secretary of HHS Homeland
Security or defense
okay
um
the Pfizer bioentec vaccine is approved
does that mean now that they've approved
this vaccine moderna and Johnson and
Johnson will lose eua
that's my question
because what I read from you is from
fda.gov it's from the government website
let me let me show you got that you got
the News Guard certified right here and
this is this is really interesting news
guard says the FDA does not correct
errors they don't reveal who's in charge
what and they don't provide the names of
content creators that I find fascinating
but this is a government website yeah
all right we're supposed to be basing
everything off what the government says
we've got FDA approval they say in order
to receive eua there must be no
alternative
now I could simply argue this they all
already have emergency use authorization
it says it doesn't say you immediately
lose it oh come on
I mean okay so so you're not supposed to
give emergency authorization to these
other ones because they already had it
they're just it's okay well this is the
question I'm asking is the FDA now going
to come in and revoke that eua from
moderna and Johnson and Johnson and just
say Pfizer is the one that's approved
because it is it literally is I mean FDA
said they approved I guess the question
is will they or and should the two
different questions should they um there
is I don't think so there's a there's a
letter that from to the FDA explaining
that they are legally distinct even
though the same formulation because
marketing something under a brand is
specific but that doesn't change the
fact that there is an FDA some people
said they're like oh it's not really FDA
approved because under a different name
and I'm like no there is an effective
alternative treatment available FDA
approved under Community oh but it's not
available yet Community right is it
yesterday you were saying it's not
available yet no no I don't know if it's
available oh okay I think people people
have said so I'm wondering you call your
doctor and ask is community available I
honestly don't know pretty soon there'll
be commercials absolutely but my
question is very very simple then
moderna and John are there stocks going
to plummet now I I would wonder if they
could make the argument again I'm not a
a pharmacologist I don't know but are
there different medical circumstances
where one vaccine would be preferable to
the other right now it seems like which
one are you going to get like I don't
know CVS has the Johnson and Johnson and
Walgreens has I just no one seemed to
know which one they were getting or why
most people I know got Johnson Johnson
because it was one shot right
um but otherwise they didn't know so the
only argument I would say is if they can
say for these reasons people who have X
Y or Z
genetic makeup I don't know even know
how to describe this sure they should
get moderna so even though pfizers is
the one pfizers is the one that's now
Community but you need Johnson and
Johnson for X reason so we still have
emergency youth authorization that's how
I would argue it so I've got this from
fda.gov this is a document says Pfizer
bionic covet vaccine eua Loa reissued
August 23.
uh there is a footnote that says the
licensed vaccine has the same
formulation as the emergency use
authorization authorized a vaccine and
the products can be used interchangeably
to provide the vaccine series
vaccination Series without presenting
any safety or Effectiveness concerns the
products are legally distinct with
certain differences that do not impact
safety or Effectiveness well didn't the
one guy from the FDA just leave to go
join the board of Pfizer that made the
news the other day and people were like
well that's kind of curious like you
just yeah so you just left the FDA no no
no no that's that's from years ago
I thought that was just years ago really
yeah over two years ago two people did
step down yeah that was that was because
they're pushing for boosters before
they've been approved and they were
upset about that then I just saw that
also but now I'm gonna look and make
sure it's not fake News June 27 2019.
former FDA commissioner Scott Gottlieb
joins Pfizer board of directors oh I'm
sorry you're saying that the news is
that Scott Lee uh left the FDA now and
went back to Pfizer this is the guy that
resigned from the FDA just went back to
Pfizer as a story says former FDA
commissioner Scott Gottlieb joins
Pfizer's board of directors and this is
from 2019. okay but you're saying he
went from Pfizer to the FDA I saw
something that's uh so I might have seen
something that was not accurate so
that's why I don't even want to continue
talking to to be fair I saw the same
thing and I was a little surprised too
but I didn't read the article and the
only reason was what is bringing that up
is to say well then maybe that explains
why one got the uh the FDA approval and
the other one did it exactly not that we
would ever think you never see four-star
generals go work for Raytheon for
example or yeah there's never any of
that like like you know posturing
between I I I don't I don't say that
story it could be that we're Googling it
but I see CNBC from a day ago saying
that he serves on the board of Pfizer
not the FDA so I think maybe people got
it mixed up do you see the new vaccine
from Modern is going to be called Spike
facts no way really yeah it's all four
sorry
vaccines Spike Backs from moderna that's
they see all the people who got tattoos
of their like teen vaccination no it's
so weird man so to the bottom of this
community
maybe it's not available yet and that's
why they're able to continue the
emergency authorization use for the
generics possibly if Community is
available then by the fda's on standards
they've got to drop maybe they don't
have to drop the emergency because
they've already right they're not
allowed to continue to give more maybe
they're allowed to continue doing it
because revoking an eua is different
from it from giving one I keep laughing
because I already see the community
commercials and like the mother and
daughter making a pie and the dad's out
and they're like if you need to ask your
doctor about community and then they
list all the symptoms right like don't
take Community if you have boom boom
boom if you have teeth if you have hair
yeah
they actually do say in the in the FDA
approval letter and the product
information for Community there is no
information on long-term effects those
studies are ongoing and they're
currently undergoing trials so yeah so
people have concerns about that and I
think it's funny when you see
um all the smears about horse medicine
and they're like oh you know ivermector
whatever which is not approved by the
FDA for use in treating covet nor is it
authorized in any way just so you guys
know because you know YouTube says it's
important
um
well I forgot I was going to say because
I was writing on YouTube
something awesome but oh yeah yeah but
they're they're you know there are
people who say like I'm concerned about
long-term health effects and then they
get made fun of and mocked and ridiculed
and I'm like
it literally says like here's what
really here's what bugs me I think too
many people who are have concerns are
getting their perception of the CDC
based on the Democrats and these
leftists I shouldn't say leftists but
like the Democrats in the establishment
left who say stupid things all the time
and the CDC literally gives you warnings
about the vaccine they tell you about
allergies they tell you about you know
uh counter indications they tell you
about all the data it's not like being
hidden on the CDC website the FDA said
everything I just read it's not hidden
on their website they're not concealing
these things yeah but you go to like you
know NPR and they're like Joe Rogan took
horse medicine and you're like that's
insane even even Oxford is doing a study
on Ivermectin which they say is
promising but not yet conclusive and so
I'm like okay thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat at and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time